Nasi viewer Mapisa Nakula,
defence minister turned National Assembly speaker
has done what few ANC public representatives ever do.
Facing dodgy dealing claims,
she resigned. Mabisa Nakula has relieved her party,
the ANC of the potential pickle of defending her
in the DA's motion of no confidence debate.
In her two page resignation statement under the Parliament letterhead,
Mabisa Nakula said
my resignation is in no way an indication or admission of guilt
regarding the allegations being leveled against me.
Allegations include 12 corruption counts
involving four point 55 million rand in bribes
allegedly solicited from a contractor between 2017 and 2019
while she was defense minister.
That emerged in papers filed at the Gauteng division of the high court
in Pretoria.
When Mapisang Makula made an interdict and discovery application
on Tuesday, the court struck the application off the urgent role
effectively clearing the way for Mapisa Nakula to be arrested
or to hand herself over
to be brought to the court for a bail application.
Peace and Marcoula maintained her innocence
as she's done since the 19 March raid at her Johannesburg home.
Her resignation as speaker
effectively the head of the legislation sphere of the state
is unprecedented. It remains to be seen
whether this is the accountability moment for Parliament
as the institution
constitutionally required to oversee the government
and hold it to account. Next month
elections will have a role in that.
On Thursday 4 April,
Mapita Nakula appeared at the Magistrate court in Pretoria
to Apply for bail. Her husband
Charles Nakula and former National Assembly speaker
Balega Mbette sat in the front row of courtroom eight.
Mapee Sagamakula claimed South African prisons are riddled with gangs
and claimed
that the facilities do not have the capability to ensure her safety.
After a short recess,
Magistrate Ushta Hasan granted Mape Sagamakula 50,000 rand bail.
The state requested
that she hands her passport over to the investigating officer
and that she does not contact any of the witnesses in the case.
This is a developing story.
Stay informed and subscribe to Daily Maverick on YouTube
or follow us on all other social media platforms for more news,
more videos and in depth analysis.